Speaker 1: Let's look at here's a question
that we've been asking for a while, and that
question is.
Are all of these investigations into Trump
going to hurt his approval rating?
And on the one hand, if approval.
Reacted to the real world.
The answer would be it sure as hell should
look at all of the legal trouble and wrongdoing
that we've learned about just in the last
six weeks about Donald Trump.
But when you're dealing with a cult, it doesn't
always work that way.
And indeed, Trump's support remains unmoved
by investigations, poll finds.
This is in The New York Times is the upshot.
And it says even during peak crises during
his presidency, views of him were static.
Post-Presidency polls have continued the trend.
The American public's view of Trump.
Is remarkably stable across a number of different
measures in recent months, even as he faces
multiple investigations and remains a central
figure in the midterm elections.
This is a New York Times Siena College poll,
and it finds 44% of voters view Trump favorably,
53% view him unfavorably.
The recent poll was fielded early this month
after news of the Justice Department's inquiry
into Trump's handling of confidential documents.
But before yesterday or the day before yesterday's
lawsuit announcement, the level of Trump support
has effectively been unchanged since the last
poll in July, which was during the January
6th committee hearings.
This is a cult, folks, and that is what we
should expect.
Think about it.
Jim Jones, People's Temple.
This is the, you know, drink the Kool-Aid
disaster that we now know about and that we've
known about for decades, I should say.
It's not it's not recent news.
If you went to the followers of Jim Jones
and you said he's under investigation for
sexual assault and he's under investigation
for embezzlement and he's under investigation
for tax evasion, and we have pretty good evidence
on all of it.
Do you think that Jim Jones followers would
have said, oh, well, then I'm no, I'm not
behind him anymore?
No, because it was a cult.
And that is how cult leaders work when you
don't care about reality.
To start your support of Trump, reality isn't
going to dissuade you from your support of
Trump.
And when he said, I could shoot someone on
Fifth Avenue and I wouldn't lose support,
he wasn't wrong.
That's exactly right.
And if he did shoot someone on Fifth Avenue,
we all know how it would go.
It would be.
Well, he was provoked.
It was self-defense.
There was a violent Antifa or BLM member who
was doing something to Trump.
That's how it would go.
It wouldn't necessarily be.
It's great that he shot someone, although
he probably would be able to find that.
You'd probably find some people who say that
the person he shot was one of those pedophiles
that Q Anon is fighting against or whatever.
But for the most part, people go, now, I don't
know, it was self-defense.
You got to understand the circumstances.
And he's there's threats to his life all the
time.
He reasonably feared for it.
And he's absolutely right when he said I would
be able to shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
not lose any support.
So it shouldn't surprise us that Trump's approval
hasn't diminished at all.
But it raises questions about what happens
with Trump ism in 2022 and in 2024, which
will be something we look at extensively in
the next few weeks leading up to these midterm
elections, which are now imminent.
We're now looking at looking at what is it,
five and a half, six weeks or so from now.
Make sure that you're following me on Twitter
at D Pacman and let me know what you think.
Is there anything at this point that could
erode Trump's support among the core supporters
that are mostly everything that he has left
or all that he has left?
Better said.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, a community
funded program.
We depend on the gracious and generous support
of so many in our audience.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You will get access to the bonus show.
You will get access to the daily commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show.
You will be invited to the members only town
halls and have priority access to the regular
town halls.
There are so many great benefits that you
can take advantage of by signing up at join
Packman dot com.